[Music]
good evening good evening everybody I'm
Jim Bell I'm a professor of astronomy at
the Cornell and it's wonderful wonderful
to be here at the Cornell Club
surrounded by Cornell Ian's go big red
thank you so much for for coming out
tonight I want to thank the folks Kari
and everyone from the Cornell Club for
for setting this up this evening and
it's really really great if you guys to
do this so we can share some of the
really exciting stuff going on on campus
I also want to just take a moment and
recognize a couple of folks my my editor
Steven Morrow is in the audience from
from Dutton thank you so much for your
your support and Steven was one of the
very first believers in this project and
I'm very very grateful and I'm not sure
if Michael Barret made it this evening
but he may come in a little bit my agent
from distal and God are extremely
helpful and motivational guy and finally
I just wanted to recognize one of my
authorial heroes in the world
Davis Oval here in the front row who's
been a just an incredible supporter of
this project as a as a scientist as an
astronomer as a father I love Galileo's
daughters one of my favorite books and
and thank you so much for your support
and for coming this evening so so I'm
the representative of a large team of
people scientists engineers faculty
staff students at Cornell up in Ithaca
at Jet Propulsion lab in Pasadena at
universities and government laboratories
literally literally around the world who
are bringing these these Rovers to life
if you will
traveling across across Mars traveling
now in the as my friend Steve Squyres
would say 1,040 fifth day of their
90-day mission on the red planet Rovers
have survived much much longer than we
ever thought
they would and and what I'd like to do
tonight is is share with you some some
pictures and some stories and some more
pictures and some more stories about
what Spirit and Opportunity have done
and what they are continuing to do every
day on Mars and it really starts with
this I like to show this this photo of
spirit and this is this is spirit in
Florida in 2003 just before launch in
the clean room with all the engineers
and their nice clean bunny suits and I
like to show this because it gives
people a sense of the size of the Rovers
some people think the Rovers are little
Tonka trucks some people think they're
big monster trucks there's something in
between they are sort of the size of
small golf carts and you can see six
wheels each wheel independently powered
power steering power brakes power
windows you know the whole nine yards
solar panel this is solar solar panel on
top we use the Sun to recharge the
batteries and run the instruments and
drive every single day and then the
cameras that we control from from
Cornell in Ithaca are up here on this
mast the mast is about a meter and a
half high about the height of a typical
10 year old kid and that's our
perspective on the world this is where
all the color images come from on both
Rovers Spirit and Opportunity are
identical identical twins just like
twins they each have their
idiosyncrasies I'll talk a little bit
about each of them and the cameras are
up here and there's also an arm it's
kind of hard to see I'll show a better
picture of it in a bit an arm that has
instruments on the end that allow us to
touch the rocks and sample their
chemistry in there their mineralogy so I
like to show that to give people a sense
of scale and the size of these vehicles
now the other thing to mention is that
they're not tearing across the ground
making rooster tails the maximum speed
of the Rovers is about 5 centimeters per
second so that's like this and that's
really moving
so it's very very slow slow motion
exploration so the trick between
2000-2003 was to get those two robots
folded up into the top of nose cones of
to Delta Rockets and successfully
launched it was a real marathon race
lots lots of thousands of people around
the country involved and putting them
together we got them to the launch pad
spirit launching in June an opportunity
in July of 2003 and the the goal was to
get them just two specific places on
Mars and this was this is one slide that
summarizes about three years and 200
people's worth of activity where do you
send two Rovers to go to Mars sometimes
when I give a talk to school kids I'll
ask them where would you send two robots
to study the earth that's a hard thing
to do it's a big planet it's diverse but
we had to choose and ultimately we chose
two places one for the geology this
place called Gusev it's a crater a big
hole in the ground created by an
asteroid or comet that's about the size
of Connecticut for scale okay it's 160
kilometers across and there's this
beautiful channel that flows into it
flows downhill that is dry now but that
we think used to have water in it and so
the hypothesis is that this may have
been an ancient Crater Lake at one point
in the past and what a great environment
to study life on Earth ancient Crater
Lake lake beds and sedimentary deposits
like that and so the hypothesis was
maybe this was a place where we could
find evidence for life or at least the
conditions conducive to life to have
been there maybe that would be good
place sort of a geology beacon saying
hey maybe this is a great place to send
a rover it just kind of blows me away
that the celestial mechanics engineers
can point a rocket from the earth and
land in the center of a tiny little hole
on a planet 150 million miles away Isaac
Newton ladies and gentlemen yes
meanwhile a spirit sister Opportunity is
on the other side of the planet in a
place called Meridiani Planum the plains
of the meridian it's on the prime
meridian zero longitude of mars and it's
a place where one of the or
in fact the orbiter that NASA just lost
the Mars Global Surveyor one of the
orbiters found this huge deposit of a
mineral called hematite fe2o3 iron oxide
rust if you will a mineral that in the
way it was found on Mars often on the
earth is formed in liquid water and so
there's sort of a mineral beacon saying
hey this might be a great place to send
a rover to look for past evidence of
water or past evidence of a habitable
environment so spirit to Gusev
opportunity to Meridiani Planum 12 Mars
time zones away the the Sun never sets
on the Cornell Martian Empire now people
have asked well how many pictures have
had the Rovers taken and the answer
right now is about a hundred and
sixty-five thousand when the book was
being put together that number was about
a hundred and fifty thousand and so I
said to Steven can we can we put about
120,000 pictures in the book would that
be all right
well no Jim you know maybe you can get
150 to 200 we ended up with about 150 in
the book and so it's a very difficult
thing to pick your favorite pictures if
any of you are parents and somebody asks
which one is your favorite kid you
understand the complexity of answering
that question I don't know if I have a
favorite picture but I can sort of rank
them and sort them and I saved on my
laptop here as we were going through
this just images that came down photos
that came down that we're like wow
that's just spectacular or whatever
that's different kinds of criteria so I
had to come up with some kind of
criteria so my first very scientific one
was that that's just Purdy and my own
kids helped with this sometimes some of
them add a whole other range of these
that I'll go through some of them are
composed photographically and this is
sort of where the subtitle for the book
comes from and that we have had I claim
the luxury compared to past missions of
being able to think like photographers
once in a while we can stop and and add
to the width or the height of a frame to
give it a different aspect ratio we can
choose to put pieces of the rover in the
foreground of the photos to give it a
sense of depth we can choose the time of
day to make the shadows longer and the
text
is really enhanced we can choose which
kind of filters to use so these are all
things that landscape photographers take
for granted on the earth but it's
something that's incredibly rare and
space photography usually you're just
flying past something and you're just
going to take a picture of it no matter
what it is you just got to get it and
get it in the can or the previous
missions to Mars had pretty good cameras
but very very tiny little data pipes to
get the data back to the earth not much
bandwidth we've got a huge amount of
bandwidth because we relay our images up
through the NASA orbiters and back to
the earth we've had almost three years
on the surface and we've got the highest
resolution cameras ever sent to Mars
those combinations of things have
allowed us once in a while to think like
photographers which is a real luxury
compared to past missions some of them
are historical images the first one of
these biggest one of those all of them
have some compelling scientific value
and all of them have a picture a story
behind the picture and and and so I
tried to pick some of those out and of
course the talk is the condensed version
of the book which goes into in much more
detail
but a very very difficult thing to do to
try to try to cull this amazing amazing
collection of photos so I'll start by
showing some examples from from spirit
the first rover to land on the 4th of
January 2004 and what did spirit what
has Spirit done here's a map of the
center of Gusev crater and spirit landed
in the plains here we drove over to a
crater called Bonneville and then we
drove across the plains in this long
trek over three months to get to the
hills which we knew would be exciting
just for for reference to go from here
to here to here took about five months
for the rover and that distance if we
were to get together and walk it maybe
stopping for a drink or some lunch over
here that would probably take us about
three hours just walking in so we're
talking slow motion exploration very
slow this is the best way that we can
explore Mars right now and it's very
slow very methodical and of course being
group of excitable scientists and
geologists and rockhounds we couldn't
just go from there there we stopped we
poked at rocks and soils and pick things
up and drilled holes very very exciting
and
and we didn't know if we would make it
we thought we might be living 90 days we
thought we might be able to drive five
or six hundred meters 90 days and 500
meters later we were here and we still
had all this way to go we finally made
it spent a year in earth year climbing
these hills that switchback II to keep
the solar panels oriented into the Sun
cresting over the summit I'll show you
some pictures from there driving down
the backside past some beautiful sand
dunes I'll show you a picture of across
a feature called home plate and today a
thousand and forty five days later Mars
days later spirit is sitting right down
here about 6800 meters away from where
we landed or more than four miles
driving across the terrain absolutely
funnel I still can't believe I'm saying
that
that's just phenomenal so just a small
selection of some postcards then
starting very early in the mission this
is just like any good tourists you land
unfold
get out on the ground open your eyes and
take a good panoramic look around so
this is part of our first big 360-degree
panorama it's kind of like a one of
those baby pictures I keep in my wallet
kind of picture you know your first your
first picture very emotional it was a
little bit sad to see these hills over
there because we knew that they were
layered and really compelling scientific
targets but oh man they're three and a
half kilometers away we're never going
to get to those hills right and no one
no one ever thought that the rover would
eventually be sitting on top of that
hill and now is on the other side it's a
very dusty place you can see that parts
of the airbags on the bottom here these
are beautiful white clean fabric when
the rover came bouncing in and the air
bags it got very dusty and dirty
there's sand dunes and rocks and things
that we could look at and explore with
the arm probably the what people were
most excited about on the engineering
team was that we could drive on this
stuff it wasn't a big boulder field it
wasn't a big sand dune field those of us
on the camera team were just really
excited that the cameras worked really
happy that they work I mean three years
of design and testing and development
and countless countless hours in
laboratories and so much effort by
students and staff and other
and voila we can take great pictures on
Mars lots and lots of excitement there
that picture was actually taken from up
on the lander a couple of weeks later
spirit drove off the lander we really
landed on Mars by driving that last 30
or so centimeters we turned the rover
around turned the master on and took a
picture of the lander so that last
picture was taken while the rover was up
here these are the airbags that deflated
you can see how dusty and dirty they got
these are the three sort of flower
petals that opened up to to let the
rover come out and these are this is the
ramp that the rover drove off of putting
our first rover footprints in the in the
Martian sand here and this picture it's
a beautifully composed shot to me
accidentally just because of the depth
of field involved here but more
importantly there's this is this is a
picture I think I most commonly see on
the walls of the cubicles of my
engineering friends at JPL because so
many people were involved in putting
this together and some of it believe it
or not is not rocket science some of it
is welding and stitching and running
cables and you know building motors and
just really hard hard to engineering and
so many so many folks are just
incredibly proud to see their equipment
having done its job perfectly it's going
to be there on Mars forever it's going
to be a museum someday in my opinion
having seen it you know do its job
perfectly and then sitting in this
literally alien environment was very
very emotional view for for lots of
folks involved here's a nice example
from about 53 days in the spirits
mission of a black and white late in the
day image of some really nice volcanic
rocks this is a large slab of volcanic
rock it's about half a meter or so long
it's made of the same kind of stuff -
any kind of minerals you'd find in
volcanic rocks and places like Hawaii or
Iceland basaltic rocks and it's one of
the first times that we could take
pictures late in the afternoon and we
weren't expecting it at least I wasn't
expecting how it sort of
beautifully stark and contrast II it
turned out to be because we're
solar-powered we usually run the rover
when the Sun is high in the sky that's
when we get our most of our power and to
go late in the day or early in the
morning we sometimes will have to dip
into the batteries and use the battery
power and that's risky because we need
those batteries to survive the night
those batteries have to keep the heaters
running inside the rover so that even
though it's 150 degrees below zero out
at night it doesn't get below about
minus 40 or so inside the rover so the
electronics can stay nice and cozy so
the most important thing we can do with
that solar power every day is recharge
the batteries that's number one because
you want to survive the night and
anything else that's any power that's
left on top of that is is gravy for
science or driving or whatever so
staying up late in the afternoon like
this was a little bit risky because we
had to tap into those batteries but boy
it really paid off in terms of the
photography and scientifically the folks
who study volcanic rocks on Mars were
incredibly excited about all the
textures on these rocks and the ability
to pull out much more geologic detail
this low lighting the idd salute this is
a picture of some of the instruments on
the end of the arm and those two words
probably don't mean much I'll try to
explain what so the rover has an arm and
it's just like a human arm with the
shoulder and an elbow and a wrist and
four fingers on the end of the arm
you're seeing the end of the arm the
wrist and the four fingers here but
partly because it's NASA and things
can't be simple it's not called an arm
it's called an instrument deployment
device or the idd and when you say well
that's the same number letters as arm it
don't don't go there so so occasionally
what what we would do the engineers who
design the arm and the instruments would
ask us occasionally to lift the arm up
and get it close to the cameras and take
pictures of the instruments to see if
the grinding bits were wearing down or
there's a rock jammed in something or
whatever so occasionally the arm would
come up and do this sort of mini salute
so that was the idd salute so this is a
it's a lovely engineering health
assessment picture the microscope is
here there's two spectrometers you can't
see one that's hidden there there
the end of one and this is the rock
abrasion tool or rat and so this was a
diagnostic image of the rat which is a
wonderful incredible machine built here
in Manhattan by a small company called
honeybee robotics crawling with Cornell
engineers and others but this device
which is about the size of a soda can
can drill into some of the hardest rocks
that we can find on the earth down to
about a centimeter or so with about the
power of a 15 watt refrigerator light
bulb so it's a fascinating bit of
engineering a low-power way to get below
the dust and into the interiors of the
rocks and get these other instruments
into the inside so it's a beautiful shot
of the rat and it's a health assessment
picture and it's all those things but
the real story behind this picture is
this this plate right here which is a
cable cover it's there's a plug
underneath this and there's some cables
going in so this is a protective cable
cover with a beautiful American flag on
it
and the story here is that we started
all the instrument teams started doing
the instrument fabrication in 2000 and I
sick new tintin a particular week in
2003 and so the clock was ticking the
schedule was incredibly tight we
originally we won a competition at
Cornell to lead the science
investigation on the rovers and our
competition we proposed one Rover and
NASA came back and said later we want to
reduce the risk so we want to send - and
so they asked Steve Squyres the leader
of the project you know would you mind
if we sent two and you know Steve
thought about it for a millisecond or so
and say oh of course
of course and they said fine we'll give
you a little extra money but we're not
going to give you an extra time so all
of a sudden our work got doubled and so
the schedule was insane I mean
absolutely insane compressed schedule
and so the folks here in Manhattan had
to build two of these plus the various
test models and all that kind of stuff
and they were deep deep inside the the
testing and development schedule and
falling behind in parts of it when of
course the world changed entirely on
9/11 here in Manhattan
unlike almost everybody else in the
world that the folks at honeybee I don't
think they really had a chance to stop
and think about what happened and how
the world had changed and grieve for
their friends and colleagues here in the
city they had to press on because the
Rockets going to leave without them they
had to keep going and and and they did
it they got there they got the rats
there they work beautifully but still as
they were nearing the end of this
process they the folks wanted to come up
with some way to remember memorialize
all those events that changed this city
that changed the world so much and so
these little cable covers these pieces
of aluminum are actually pieces of
aluminum from the World Trade Center
towers they negotiated with mayor
Giuliani's office and got some pieces of
metal and very carefully lovingly and
emotionally machined them put some
beautiful decals on and their little
little memorials up there on spirit and
opportunity to to that that day that the
world changed that's what gets me in
this picture most of us on the team are
geologists and rock bunkers but there
are a few airheads
meteorologists who occasionally like to
look up and so we will occasionally
point the Rovers up into the sky to look
at clouds or dust in the atmosphere or
the sunset and the projector is having a
blast with this one
but anyway it's still it's a beautiful
picture of the sunset on Mars we happen
to catch it as the Sun was just going
beyond the rim of the crater 50 miles
away 80 kilometers away and the cool
thing for me besides the fact that you
know I'm sitting there in my office in
Ithaca on a sunny day and the sun is
shining on my desk and I'm looking at a
picture taken a few minutes ago of the
sun shining on Mars you know it's the
same Sun we live in the same solar
system two worlds one Sun it's one of
our mottos on our calibration target and
and you know we're looking at sunsets on
another world folks I mean this is
incredible so that's one thing there's
also some really cool science going on
here because the Martian sky is kind of
the OP
- the earth sky earth sky is blue during
the daytime as the Sun sets the Sun in
the skies to turn this red as the Sun is
going through all that muck in the
atmosphere two o'clock in the afternoon
if you live in LA and on Mars it's just
the opposite the sky is red during the
daytime because of the dust in the
atmosphere and as the Sun is setting the
sky lights up and turns this kind of
bluish color in this like hot-air
balloon shape the projector is making it
much more dramatic than it is here but
it turns a distinctly bluish color
compared to the sky during the day and
so it's backwards from Mars the Sun from
Earth the Sun sets on Mars are kind of
blueish compared to the Sun sets on the
earth that's that seems like a beautiful
thing to me so we got to those hills and
spirit wasn't necessarily built as a
hill climbing robot but it turned out to
be a great hill climber she was
struggling up the slopes dislodging
rocks up these fifteen twenty
twenty-five degrees slopes we saw
outcrop for the first time and an
outcrop is a Holy Grail word for
geologists if you go to a party and
they're geologists there if you whisper
outcrop in the back they'll Kirkup you
really will try it try it it works rock
that's formed and altered in place for
the first time we'd been out on these
Plains way out here we drove up these
hills and now we're seeing real evidence
for the first time with spirit that
water had interacted with these rocks a
very small amount but we'd seen nothing
before then so we're going after the
water story we didn't find any evidence
where we landed and we started seeing
this evidence as we drove up the hills
different kinds of minerals and coatings
for example in the rocks but beyond that
it was just really dramatic to have this
this this view of these beautiful rocks
in the near field the plains off in the
distance the rim of a crater ten
kilometres away in the wall of the
crater 80 kilometres off in the distance
a real sense of depth when you pan
through pan and zoom through these
photos and we finally made it up to the
summit after all that switch backing for
a year keeping the solar panels oriented
into the Sun and we were so happy and so
proud we call this our Everest panorama
because we crusted the summit it is not
a mountain it's a hill it's about a
hundred 110 meters 300 so feet above the
plains but still it was a dramatic climb
it's a very windy place you can see all
these little sand dunes and ripples up
there you'll see a dust devil come in
through the frame here it actually moved
there's two two of them because it moved
in the time that we rotated the filters
you can see our tracks up here very wind
scoured wind carved rocks it's a very
dusty and windy place and in fact this
is where we had our first of what have
been several sort of magical wind
cleaning events on the rover we assumed
that one of the things that might kill
us is dust settling out of the
atmosphere because of the famous Martian
dust storms and we've got solar panels
and they're just going to get dirty and
dusty with time and our power would
slowly drop and we were seeing that
happen we saw our power slowly dropping
as the dust was settling on the panels
and then literally overnight when we
were up here at the summit our power
jumped up the next morning 20% higher
than it had been and we took pictures of
the deck and we could see that it had
been swept clean by some gust of wind or
maybe one of these dust devils we're not
sure but it's a windy place and and that
wind which you can't control as much as
we'd like to take credit for it that
wind has helped in keeping these Rovers
alive for so long because it just cleans
the dust off cleans cleans the dust off
the decks keeps our power high so we
liked being up in the summit and getting
more power we press the de summit went
down the other side into the the basin
to the South that we could tell was
interesting from orbit and passed by
these beautiful sand dunes this is an
enhanced false color image it makes the
dunes appear much bluer than they really
are but they're very dark and black and
so this is part of it what is a huge
sand dune field that we drove past this
is about 50 meters 50 yards or so of it
and we nuzzled up to it and we made a
bunch of measurements with the arm but
we couldn't go into it because we knew
it would be kind of a rover death trap
if we would just slip and slide and not
not move anywhere but we really wanted
to study it because not only is it
beautiful stuff but it's sand is
everywhere on Mars and it's very this is
very typical of what sand is like on
Mars
it's very different than sand on the
earth sand on the earth is quartz it's
light it's yellowish or white sand on
Mars is black basalt 'ok it's volcanic
it's like a like a black sand beach in
hawaii fundamentally completely
different kinds of minerals going on
there and so here is a chance of
actually studying this stuff that's all
over the planet so we took it and took
some pretty nice photos in the
neighborhood and then most recently on
spirit we were involved in taking what's
called our McMurdo panorama and this
took more than five months to take this
picture
we started in April here we ended in
September over there
this was taken while Spirit was parked
on the side of a hill for the Martian
winter and it was winter the power was
very low we had enough power every day
to recharge the batteries and maybe do
one or two more things
no driving not enough power to drive but
we could recharge the batteries take a
few pictures go to sleep and so or make
some measurements with the arm and so
every day or every third or fourth day
we'd take some pictures this is where
spirit was driving when the wheel
stopped working the front right wheel
stopped working and it started dragging
the wheel will come back at that in a
moment it started dragging the wheel
through the soil exposing this bright
salty material and we actually measured
some of the the composition of this
salty stuff it's not like table salt
it's a magnesium sulfate salt very
similar to Epsom salt anybody has epsom
salt at home it's the same kind of
minerals but we were we were scrambling
and running away from this stuff as
quickly as we could because we had to
get the rover tilted onto a hill to get
those solar panels into the Sun or
otherwise we wouldn't survive the winter
so we still haven't really characterized
this stuff very well we passed the
winter solstice the Sun is coming back
up again powers going up again and now
spirit is coming alive again we've moved
the rover a little bit we're heading
towards that rock over this coming week
to make some detailed measurements and
we're going to try to we're actually
having a big debate now about whether
they go back into this salty stuff or
not because we might get stuck in it but
it could also be the most compelling
material to tell us something about the
water story here in Gusev crater why is
there this salty mineral deposit just
below the surface we don't
no and it's eating away at a bunch of us
we don't know what it's doing that so
there's a big debate and we get along
really well as a team but there's lots
of pros and cons and we're just starting
to have that debate now that spirits
getting power again we will have to
drive with this gimpy right front wheel
but we can drive backwards and kind of
drag it launched a knee like through the
through the soils so we won't have as
much mobility as we used to have but
we'll still be able to drive around
quite a bit so spirit is basically right
about here right now sitting on this
this dis layered stuff here making some
measurements and getting ready to
reinvigorate its mission for it heading
into its third Martian summer meanwhile
that was only half the presentation
because we had this completely separate
completely independent spacecraft called
opportunity on the other side of Mars in
a very different place and almost as
different a place as you can imagine
being from from Gusev crater Opportunity
has been phenomenal driver as well we
landed inside of a small crater called
Eagle crater that is about the size of
this room 20 meters or so across bounced
right into this little crater was a
beautiful interplanetary hole-in-one
partly why it's called Eagle crater for
you golfers out there and then that we
spent almost two months driving around
inside this this little crater for
reasons that I'll talk about and then
drove across the plains to an even
bigger crater called endurance endurance
is about the size of the Rose Bowl
football stadium we spent eight months
driving around inside that crater and
Eagle endurance and then since then
we've been driving south for two years
now across the plains getting stuck in
the sand getting stuck on the rim of a
crater and eventually getting down to
our big goal here Victoria crater which
is a half a mile wide hole in the ground
that we've just arrived at recently in
for opportunity's mission the theme is
using craters as sort of road cuts as
ways to see into the subsurface sort of
for free mother nature creates these
giant holes from asteroid and comet
impacts a small hole digs a little bit
down a big
whole digs deeper bigger hole still
deeper still so we're sampling the
Martian subsurface by driving past and
probing these different layers
underground at the craters total
distance so far 9600 meters more than
six miles of driving opportunity is
about to become the first interplanetary
10k competitor this first shot is a view
of Eagle crater taken as we were driving
out after we had spent our two months
inside this little tiny hole in the
ground that was our world for the for
the rover missions for the first two
months you'll see the lander here will
zoom in this is the same kind of Lander
that delivered spirit and the tracks
coming out of the crater here and you
can see all these tracks all over the
place we really made a mess was a good
thing it's not a national park right
because we really trashed it made a
beeline for this beautiful outcrop
obviously outcrop beautiful outcrop in
the wall of the crater here that turns
out to be some of the most spectacular
rocks ever found on the surface of Mars
and we could see when even when the
rover was on the lander we could see
that that rock was layered even from
that distance that it was very finely
layered and geologists are all about
layers because that tells you that the
environment is changing some process
lays down rock and that process changes
and then another process comes along and
lays down maybe the same kind maybe the
different kind of rock and so if you can
read the layers it's like opening a book
and reading the pages and deeper you go
in the surface the farther back in time
that geologic book can take you so in
the very first image from opportunity we
can see those layers and so it was very
very exciting opportunity is sort of the
lucky sister of the two-spirit has
always had to work and scramble and
climb hills and all that to to eke out
the water story at Gusev an opportunity
has just had it handed to her the hold
right there here you go here's the whole
story well the first thing we did
driving off that Lander we looked down
at our feet to take high-resolution
pictures on the ground and I remember
when when this image came back and we
ah the ground covered with these little
spherical grains millions and millions
of spherical grains all over the ground
and I mean there were audible gasps
among the team when these images popped
up on the screens what the heck is going
on y-you know what's what's what's
happening here this is an area of the
ground about the size of a deck of cards
and you're seeing grains round grains
that are about the size of bb's or ball
bearings just covering the ground and
they are this is a microscope image
taken by the microscope on the arm
that's been colorized with the data from
the the pan cams on the mast so the
microscope is in the color camera it's
just black and white so we colorize it
and we could tell that these little
spheres were less red or more blue than
the surroundings and so they became
known as blueberries so the name come
came from it's not that they're chewy
and fruity or anything like that and so
we saw the blueberries everywhere and it
quickly became imperative to figure out
what these things are and what are they
where did they come from many different
hypotheses started getting thrown around
are they from volcanic explosions
creating little glass beads are they
from impact craters at some other
process and what we could tell is that
there was a trail of them leading over
to that outcrop that we could see on the
rim of the crater so we drove over to
the the outcrop very quickly and used
our rat to drill into the rocks into
these layered rocks and this is an
example of a rat hole humans creating a
mess on another planet so this is about
the size of the top of a soda can again
okay just a hole in the ground like this
that's about about a centimeter or so
deep and it turned out to be extremely
easy to drill into this rock it was
really soft
this is went right in as opposed to the
rocks the volcanic rocks that Spirit was
grinding into that took hours and hours
and hours to go down a millimeter or two
this stuff was very very soft you may or
may not be able to tell there's a couple
of ground down blueberries in here
they were shaved down as the rat was
shaving into the rock turns out that
this this sedimentary this rock is a
sedimentary rock that's loaded
blueberries it's not volcanic it's
loaded with sulfur and chlorine and
bromine it's a salty deposit it's very
much in chemistry very much like the
kinds of deposits you find in places
like the Bonneville Salt Flats or Death
Valley where you've had salty water
liquid water that evaporates that
precipitates minerals behind leaving
them on the ground loaded with sulfur
and chlorine bromine and sodium chlorine
on the earth on Mars the salt sir at
least in this place appeared to be
mostly sulfur rich so we instantly knew
that we were dealing with a very
different interesting kind of rock not a
volcanic rock we found a place not far
from here
where a bunch of these little
blueberries had rolled into a depression
and it was called the berry bowls about
that big and we put the instruments on
the collection of blueberries in the
berry Bowl because the berries are too
small for the instruments to measure
individually so we needed a collection
of them and then we made the same
measurement on another part of the same
rock that didn't have any berries on it
so we could look at the difference and
when we looked at the difference what we
saw was that the berries are made of
hematite fe2o3
so these little round grains scattered
all over the ground are the thing that
we saw in the picture from orbit that
told us go visit this place and that was
a really satisfying moment to make the
connection to see the ground truth
between the remote sensing from orbit
and then to be on the ground and see
what is it that gave me that that
strange signal it's these little blue
berries well the last thing any of us
imagined of course but very very
satisfying scientifically to see that
and we think because they're intimately
associated with this this sedimentary
salty rock we think they're a kind of
formation called a concretion which you
can find in the desert southwest of Utah
for example places where there's been a
lot of water saturating very porous rock
and that water has iron and other things
in solution and as that water is either
evaporating or slowly receding the
minerals precipitate out of the water
just like stalactites or stalagmites in
a cave they precipitate out and if it's
nice and slow and even they grow in
these perfect spheres and that's what we
think these little blueberries are
little sphere
Oh grains that are formed as as water is
evaporating and precipitating minerals
behind we can see other kinds of you can
see some of the layers in this rock we
saw some layers that were kind of curved
and swooped and these are very much like
what we see in places on earth where
there have been waves moving across the
surface and the waves are moving the
sand and that sand is eventually
lithified into a rock and it preserves
the waves in the in the layers we saw
evidence of that we saw evidence of
minerals in here sulfur bearing minerals
that have water in their mineral
structure and they require water to form
so some of the water that was there a
long time ago is still there in the
minerals preserved in these rocks and
minerals and this is extremely exciting
to realize that within a few months of
landing and putting all these pieces
together that that place that we we saw
that little crater with the lander
inside at one point in time a long time
ago that was a beach and there were
waves lapping up on a shore and it just
sort of blows your mind to realize it
now we set out to test the hypothesis
that there was liquid water on Mars
coming from the orbiters and it's
extremely rare believe me as a scientist
to set out to test a hypothesis and to
actually come up with an answer and the
answer is there was liquid water on Mars
and we have evidence for it preserved in
the rocks and minerals in the geology at
the opportunity landing site very very
exciting thing I may never again have
pictures on the cover of two science
magazines in the same year my entire
life well we wanted to test whether
little Eagle crater was just some sort
of a freakish weird place and so we
drove over to endurance crater so again
this is the size of the Rose Bowl with
all the seats big sand dunes at the
bottom here very very dangerous place
for for driving the Rovers there are
licensed Rover drivers at the Jet
Propulsion Laboratory and their job is
to help get the scientists and the
instruments to the most interesting
places and so we spent quite a bit of
time driving the rover around the rim
here looking for a way in measure
the slopes obviously have to be very
careful in places where those slopes are
60 70 80 90 degrees if the Rover drivers
made a mistake and gave the wrong
command and the rover bounces down here
ends up but its feet up in the air
that's it that's the end of the mission
there's no triple-a that's going to come
and pull us out all right that's it so a
very very careful conservative
methodical driving around here
eventually awhile in was identified we
drove opportunity down this slope right
around here and ended up right in front
of these beautifully layered exposed
rocks so we were seeing instead of at
Eagle crater we saw a few tens of
centimeters into the subsurface here
we're seeing a few meters into the
subsurface and so we're looking farther
back in time at the very top here we saw
blueberries everywhere sulfur chlorine
bromine volcanic sedimentary rocks
excuse me the same kinds of things we
saw at at Eagle crater and so we wanted
to see is this as all this layer stuff
the same kind of material this is just a
pretty picture taken from the rim
another opportunity to take very late
afternoon imaging we had actually been
doing this series of toe dips driving
the rover in a little bit into the
crater and then backing out just to see
how it reacted to these slopes some of
the Rover drivers compared this to to
driving on plywood covered with BBS you
know not an easy thing to do the rubbers
did it great they actually did better
than people did in the test bed so drive
in drive out drive in drive out look at
the the torques and all that kind of
stuff and then late in the day
opportunity took the sort of
self-portrait this is as close as we can
get to taking a picture of our cameras
right there up here on the mast there's
our shadow just a really really stunning
late afternoon picture so the end of in
the middle of the crater are those dunes
I find it out and we could use our
infrared filters to take pictures of
them these are even more dramatically
enhanced relative to human vision
because of the infrared filters than the
the dunes at El Dorado the reason we put
those infrared filters on was because we
knew there was a bunch of iron minerals
in the surface of Mars known that since
telescope days and so the different
colors in the infrared were chosen to
enhance the differences between
different kinds of iron minerals and so
we could dial in different combinations
of filters and come up with these
spectacular Andy Warhol like color
composites that enhance places that are
extra dusty or higher concentrations of
certain kinds of volcanic rocks and
minerals so there's some great science
in here and all that but it's really a
stunning picture especially if we did it
up in the book as one of these big fold
outs so you could pull this thing out
and it's just like these spectacular
rainbow of sand really it's okay it's
one of my favorites I'll admit to it and
at the end of our hour drive inside
endurance we went as far as we could
here's what that layered cliff looks
like up close so where the rover is
tilted at this 30-degree angle looking
over its shoulder taking a detailed 180
degree panorama and we see all these
beautiful layers is jumbled layer of
rocks at the top this is an impact
crater so it was cracked and jumbled you
see the cracks here full of dust but
below that jumbled layer you see all
these beautiful layers some lovely high
angle cross bedding for all you
geologists out there and you can follow
these layers across large segments of
the crater and they're deep in the
subsurface and they're loaded with
blueberries and they're loaded with
sulfur and chlorine and bromine and
salty deposits same kind of stuff that
we saw at the top of the stack so that
that watery history goes back a
significant chunk of time can't say how
much time we don't know how long it took
to lay down these sediments we don't
have any tools on the rover to tell us
the dates the radioactive age dates of
these things nobody's figured out how to
take the equipment that would fill a
laboratory the size of this room to do
radioactive age-dating and put it in a
shoebox this big and send it on a rover
that day is coming
but nobody's figured that out yet so we
can't get the absolute age dates yet we
know it's old we know it goes back to
the earliest part of Martian history
three to four billion years ago because
of the impact craters that we see in the
area around here but boy it would be
great to know how much time this really
represents because if it's a flash in a
pan geologically
that's one thing if it's a long period
of time if Mars had water on its surface
for a long period of time just like the
earth did then we can really start to
get serious when we think about life on
Mars and if life did exist on Mars and
it had time perhaps to become complex
and that's one of the Holy Grails that
we and everybody who's studying NASA is
really going after getting at that
question of could there have been life
on Mars this just became much much more
compelling this past week with the
discovery of the fact that there is
liquid water on Mars today just below
the subsurface even today so it's it's
extremely exciting to be to be studying
these kinds of places with the Rovers
now when we're not in a crater we are in
places like this this is called rub
al-khali
and that's the name of a place in Saudi
Arabia called The Empty Quarter and you
can see why it's called that this is
what Meridiani Planum looks like if
you're not in a crater we look at this
picture and I say wow what you know
stark desolate beauty okay let's get out
of here you know there's nothing to do
there it's a got a couple of colleagues
who studies sand dunes and sand ripples
and they're really excited and thrilled
by this but even even they will run out
of interesting things to to look at
after a while opportunity almost died
right in this spot actually we got stuck
in one of these little sand ripples this
is it's not a dune it's a ripple it's
only about that high it's a little mini
sand dune this one which goes right
under the rover turned out to be about
that high and it's not clear if the
rover bottomed out or not but it did get
stuck and just spun its wheels in this
sand and it wasn't smart enough it
wasn't programmed to be smart enough for
this situation to realize that it wasn't
moving forward anymore it was just
looking for stress on the wheels to tell
it to stop and didn't see any stress on
the wheels because the wheels are
spinning just fine and so it just spun
its wheels and kept sinking and dug
itself in a deep rut and it took us more
than 40 days to get the rover out of
this spot so that dramatically changed
the way that we drive and it also just
highlights how you know even though this
is doesn't look like it's a very
dangerous environment it is
dangerous environment for a vehicle like
this that that can easily get bogged
down in soft sand well we we drove south
until very recently and we finally got
to in late September October we got to
Victoria crater that goal for several
years of driving and here's what
Victoria looks like from the ground
it's an enormous the biggest hole in the
ground enormous hole in ground that
we've come across yet and there are just
some spectacular layered rocks and
cliffs this is about 20 feet high
it's another 50 foot high cliff here a
series of bays and alcoves going in and
out almost like the north coast of Kauai
a huge sand dune in the bottom it's a
half a mile across to the other side
another 50 foot high stack of layered
sedimentary rocks we have not been able
to touch this stuff yet try to get a
rover in there right it's going to be a
challenge but we desperately want to go
in we want to get the rover in to study
these these slopes in these deposits and
see if that sedimentary water rich
sulfur chlorine bromine salty history
goes farther and farther back in time
than even at endurance crater so that's
that's where opportunity is now actually
here's a view from the new orbiter we
arrived that picture you just saw was
taken right here this is a half a mile
across and we've been hopping from
promontory to promontory and now we're
up here we're just about to hop over to
the promontory on the other side of
bottomless Bay Cape Cape Verde Cape st.
Mary bottomless Bay these are all places
visited by Magellan and his and his crew
their travels around the world and of
course Victoria was Magellan ship that
made it safely back around the world so
our naming scheme is ships of
exploration so we're going to hop around
until we can find a way in we don't know
where we'll go in everybody wants to go
in but we don't want it to be a suicide
Thelma and Louise kind of drive right so
we're going to do a lot of very careful
slow methodical stereo mapping of the
slopes and find a way to get this rover
in and access those spectacular layered
cliffs
and read further back in time in the
Martian book of geologic history so the
question everybody always asks how long
will the Rovers keep going and I used to
pretend I could give an informed answer
and my engineering colleagues would
built the Rovers used to pretend that
they could give an answer to but even
the people who built the Rovers have no
idea
no one knows they are so far beyond
their design lifetime they each have a
little bit of you know aged age-related
issues the shoulder joint on
opportunity's arm has been a little
flaky spirit has a bum right front wheel
you know these things happen with age
you know agent maturity but they're
still both mobile the instruments are
working well we still find new and
interesting places we're not sitting in
one place just doing nothing I think
we're just going to drive them until the
wheels fall off literally I have I've
compared the Rovers to wild animals
released into their native habitat and
that's where they are they are where
they were built to be they love the cold
they love the dry and and they are
independent little spacecraft they need
the Sun Sun recharges the batteries the
batteries come up to 80% of their charge
potential still three years after the
missions landing and and so we're just
going to keep going this is one of my
favorite cartoons eat my Martian dust
rabbit and to Mars years and still
roving across the surface and finally I
just want to invite you all to follow
along I'll leave these websites up there
both at Cornell and JPL and of course a
shameless plug for the book which has a
lot of these stories in much more detail
and I'll leave you all alone out there
with an invitation the next time you're
on campus please come by Space Sciences
Building maybe over a reunion weekend or
something I think we'll still be driving
the Rovers in June and we'd be glad to
show you our camera Operations Center
and share with you our our little piece
of Mars
there's faculty/staff a huge number of
students involved in this great
opportunities for them and
and really it's it's a spectacular of
success for not only for Cornell but for
NASA and the nation and I think the
future of our space exploration program
so thank you again for coming this
evening now I just would be happy to do
some question and answers and I've been
asked to tell you to wait for the
microphone if you have a question I'm
not sure where the oh there's the
microphone guy right there so if you
have a question we have to sky right
here right and if you could just stand
up to with the microphone you mentioned
that Cornell was in the competition how
did you win the competition who was a
competition and there are the
universities that are also guiding other
parts of the mission right the
competition was a NASA basically said to
anyone who wants to propose hey we're
going to send what at the time a rover
to Mars and here are the capabilities of
the rover we want to know what kind of
scientific instruments you would put on
this Rover and so we proposed a package
Steve Squyres the principal investigator
proposed a package that included the the
pan cams the the rat the spectrometers
on the arm the infrared spectrometer
that's on the mast this whole package of
about six instruments designed to study
the geology and the minerals of Mars and
so Cornell led that is the leader of
that scientific package but there are
colleagues at other universities and
government laboratories who are on this
team and we were competing against
colleagues from other universities and
other government laboratories with
different packages of instruments and
slightly different science goals and I
think there were about six six or so
proposals they're very big deals it's
you know many many many millions of
dollars involved and you team with the
contractors for the instruments and
they're judged by a panel of expert
engineers and scientists and ranked and
and we actually lost the competition
once
and then we lost the competition again
and then we won the competition in
around 96 or 97 and then after the two
missions that were launched in 1999
crashed NASA cancelled our Rover they
pulled the rug out from under us and
then we were reinstated in 2000 again so
it's been this crazy roller coaster over
the last 10 years and I go into it in a
lot of detail in the book and Steve
Squyres goes into in his book in some
detail as well this crazy roller coaster
ride of being winning and losing and
winning and losing and then finally
winning and having all of a sudden
mistakes doubled with two Rovers instead
of one Rover tell me about the batteries
for this thing it sounds like those are
the lifeline for the whole yeah the
whole batteries have been amazing I wish
I knew more about them technically
they're there I believe they're lithium
metal hydride batteries they're not
energizer I don't believe as much as I'd
like to probably get on that brand wagon
and and they do they come back to about
80% of their charge potential even after
three years of charge discharge so I
personally I thought and I think many
people thought that would it be another
thing that could kill us anybody's used
rechargeable batteries you can only
charge them and discharge them so many
times
eventually you throw them out and these
these batteries just come right back up
like clockwork almost every time so that
that has been a real big component of
living for so long yep
now you've had this tremendous success
where do you see the future of of Mars
exploration
you know what particular missions or
things that you want to know and find
out about Mars and what path were wait
do you think you'll approach that how
will you know Cornell Space Science be
involved will you be involved with that
right well up until up until about a
month ago there were there were six
spacecraft all active at the same time
at Mars sort of a mini little Armada of
robots studying Mars and Cornell's
involved in all of them we probably lost
the Mars Global Surveyor although
miracles happened the Soho spacecraft
was lost for six months and magically
came back so who knows maybe Mars Global
Surveyor will be back so there's a very
active program besides just these Rovers
of orbiters studying the planet the next
two missions are already defined one
launches next summer
it's a Lander called Phoenix it will go
to a region near the North Pole has a
big arm it's going to try to dig a deep
trench and look for ice in the
subsurface who knows with the
announcement last week maybe they'll
find water maybe it'll gushing geysers I
doubt it but that would be really
exciting and then the next one after
that is in 2009 is the next Rover which
is will be based on Spirit and
Opportunity but more than twice as big
about the size of a Mini Cooper
it's called Mars Science Laboratory and
we're heavily involved in the cameras
and some of the other instruments and
that as well and we'll use a lot of the
same ideas for operating vehicles on
Mars that mission that we use for these
Rovers and the goal is to drive up to 20
kilometers from the place that we land
so we can't actually land in the most
juicy scientifically interesting places
on Mars today with these vehicles we
have to land and somewhat more boring
places and drive to the juicy
interesting stuff and so that's what the
next big Rover will be able to do and it
also will have a wonderful very
sensitive organic chemistry experiment
on board to get into the subsurface and
for any evidence underground in the
shallow underground for organic
molecules question right here in the
white sweater hang on a second what do
you know about any air or atmosphere on
the planet and how do we know if there
is any right well we know there's an
atmosphere and people even with
telescopes you can see clouds moving
across the planet the polar caps coming
and going and the Viking landers in the
70s actually measured that atmosphere
and we know it's almost all co2 carbon
dioxide but it's extremely thin it's
only about 1% of the pressure in this
room so it's a very very thin almost
delicate atmosphere with a tiny tiny bit
of water vapor in there and so clouds
can sometimes condense out of the air
and form but it's not it never rains the
current atmosphere there liquid water
can't exist on the surface very surface
with the current atmosphere which is one
thing that has so many people puzzled
about this discovery last week of water
in a very near surface I mean how does
it survive there and it's not a
breathable atmosphere for us it's
extremely cold and a very very dry place
the rover's love it there's a little bit
of dust we know there are dust storms in
the Martian atmosphere that's the major
sort of weather that happens on Mars is
dust storms moving around so there are
some familiar parts like we would
recognize clouds and dust but also it's
just very very unearthed like and not a
hospitable place to go visit without a
spacesuit Yeah right here
could you use them up you mentioned the
discovery last week of water slightly
below the surface could you describe the
process of how that was found right this
is from not from the Rovers
but this is from one of the orbiters
that took pictures of an area you may
have seen these pictures of these famous
gullies these these beautiful channels
that look like they're braided river
channels formed on the sides of craters
and the assumption was that they were
formed a long time ago and over the last
seven years they've taken pictures of a
few of them over over time and they've
seen two of them actually get filled
with some kind of whitish deposit and
one hypothesis is that it might be Frost
but they're very close to the equator
and it's awfully warm and frost
shouldn't be there if you believe
physics but that's just physics right
another hypothesis is that it's salt
salty deposits left behind by salty
water that flowed out of the side of the
crater down the slope sometime in the
past seven years and evaporated leaving
this salty deposit behind we don't know
anything about the color of that stuff
about the composition all we have are
two pictures before and after and so all
of a sudden people around the country in
my business are getting trying to point
these different spacecraft instruments
at this these deposits and figure out
what they're made of is it ice is it
minerals what exactly is going on so
there's still more questions than
answers but the leading hypothesis is
that there's liquid water on Mars today
just under the surface a few meters a
few tens of meters down and it
occasionally it bursts out on in places
like crater walls
maybe it's dammed up behind some ice and
it bursts out and as it gets into that
very thin atmosphere it can't exist as a
liquid anymore so it just starts boiling
off turning into a vapor instantly as
its flowing downhill but it's going to
flow some distance few hundred meters
before it completely boils off and then
it kind of seals itself with ice back
where it came out
that process probably happens in lots of
places if we happen to see it in two
places
in a camera that has only looked at
about five percent of the surface so I'm
I can't tell you what's going on but I'm
certainly scratching my head a lot more
than I was a week ago yeah how about how
about over here
everybody in the back is shy I think you
said that the blueberries were made from
ferrous oxide why do they appear blues
that have rust colors they're not that
they're not actually blue they're red
than the than the surrounding soil so
because they're less to an astronomer
less red means more blue and that's why
they're called blueberries and they're
actually sort of grayish to very
slightly red some of them are dusty some
of them are cleaned it's actually much
more gray than blue the blueberry was
just an unfortunate name because they're
less red yes on the back there in red
shirt
can you just comment on gravity on Mars
sure the gravity is about 3/8 that of
the earth two smaller planets about half
the diameter of the earth and so the
Rovers were actually built for that
gravity and so it was actually very
somewhat difficult testing them here on
the earth because they're very fragile
for the Earth's heavy gravity they're
built for that gravity so there is a
test rover that we use for driving in
Southern California and it has doesn't
have a masters I have antennas it's been
stripped down so that it weighs about
3/8 of what it should weigh so that it
can just drive correctly and so see it's
a great great way to lose weight fast go
to Mars yeah some are on the back there
right yeah go ahead sure say when you
get the elements on laws and you want to
determine their chemical composition how
do you do that just is it transfer is it
somehow the materials are transferred no
you know we're - we're making the
measurements there there are two of
those instruments on the arm our
spectrometers their job is to measure
the elements and the minerals and they
use these little x-ray sources that
bombard the surface with x-rays and they
watch how the x-rays bounce back and the
way the x-rays bounce back depends on
how much iron or silicon or magnesium or
aluminum so we're getting a signal back
that's then put into a radio signal and
sent back to the earth so the analysis
is done there on the planet yeah
now these Rovers aren't coming back they
don't send samples back they are they
are going to be museums someday then the
next step other question the next step
beyond that that next Rover is getting
samples back I'm pretty sure sometime in
the next decade of the 21st century will
be getting samples back but that hasn't
been specifically formulated as a
specific plan yet way back white shirt
keep the microphone guy running yeah two
questions could you comment on the total
cost of the project and the funding
sources and then separate and totally
unrelated what speed does the do the
Rovers in their envelope hit the server
set write the funding sources are in
this room this is your tax dollars at
work this is all NASA government funding
the total cost for building the two
Rovers and launching them over to start
building them but three six years ago
launched them and operate them for the
first nine months of the mission the
first 90 days of the mission the total
cost is something like eight hundred and
twenty million dollars I tried to look
up what Americans spent in Donuts last
year and I think it was like nine or ten
billion dollars just put that in
perspective so it's it's you know quite
a quite a bit of money it's a large
fraction of NASA's Solar System
exploration program dedicated to Mars
NASA gets about fifteen to seventeen
billion dollars a year from the from the
two point whatever it is trillion dollar
federal budget so it's a fair slice of
of NASA's budget and it's you know half
a percent or something of the the
federal budget or something like that in
that order so it's a fair a bit of a bit
of taxpayer funding and so we're very
very receptive to the fact and aware of
the fact that you know people want
something for their investment taxpayers
are making investment in this and so
we've wanted to try to make sure we give
back and that's why we put all the
images out on the internet as soon as
they come down one of the few projects
that does that since that first 90 days
the Rovers have been operating on sort
of a year-to-year basis with extended
mission budgets that had been I don't
know the exact numbers are somewhere in
the ten to fifteen million dollar issue
ange per year to keep running these so
it's a small fraction of the
the initial investment to build them and
to to launch them and so that doesn't
those are the rough numbers and then you
had another question that I've
completely forgotten sweet this beetle
ant of the landing the rover came into
the top of the atmosphere at something
like five or six kilometers per second
and it had to come to a standstill
hovering a hundred or 200 meters above
the surface in about five and a half
minutes or so and then from there once
it was hovering and retrorockets the
cable was cut and the airbags were
dropped and they hit the surface at a
few tens of meters per second 50 60
miles an hour something like that same
kind of technology that protects all of
us in a car crash with airbags same
basic kind of technology and apparently
it works for robots to jump over here
and what what was the past that this
took to mock ours and how long did it
take I think it seemed like roughly six
or seven months right and the current to
talk about sending a band mission to
Mars is it would be a minimum of a year
and a half I'm just wondering what the
discrepancy is well that's a round-trip
we're not going to send people one-way
right it's got to be a round-trip six or
seven months is about as quick as you
can get
current rocket technology to Mars it's
just a just a big elliptical path and
you just have to wait for the planets to
line up right which is why everything
had to be built on an exact schedule
because those Rockets had to leave in a
specific window of time but yes and that
six or seven months was at a time when
Mars was very close to the earth - more
often than not it's more like eight nine
or ten months to get there each way and
then people have to spend time on the
surface and wait for the planets to
align again to come back home so it's a
year and a half two years perhaps even
three-year mission depending on how it
gets time to send people there and and
I'm very optimistic I think that that's
going to happen I think it's going to
happen in 20 30 40 years or so time
after these robots really help pave the
way a little bit better let's take one
more and then then I think we have to
cut it off anyone right here good would
you tell us about the cameras themselves
you just go down the street here and buy
a Nikon or something no these are these
are very specially designed cameras to
survive that have to survive in that
harsh environment in the in the lingo of
the consumer electronics industry they
are one megapixel cameras and I usually
get a pretty negative reaction that was
that hit one you know I can go down to
Best Buy and I can buy a 5 10 12 15
megapixel camera this is NASA technology
why isn't it you know and and I say well
it was they were designed in the mid 90s
back when a megapixel meant something
right and they were an incremental
improvement
the best cameras that had flown in space
before and that's the way NASA's space
exploration works that you can't just
fly something off the shelf that's never
been tested in space you have to
incrementally approve improve and show
that it has what they call heritage that
this system has flown in space before
and and we did that we use systems that
had been in Earth orbiting satellites
these one megapixel cameras very
specially designed to work in a very low
temperature near vacuum with the window
over the front to protect them from
getting dust inside little filter wheels
on the end so we actually take multiple
images for color we'll take a red green
and blue filter send those back to the
earth and put them together in Photoshop
or other software that we've built to to
make the color pictures so they're very
special what's that yes the two cameras
are identical they're just stereo pairs
that are we can use left and right side
to take stereo images so I think I think
we're squash the questioning for now but
I think we're going to go gather in the
back and I'd be happy to do some
signings or answer some more questions
in the back there I want to thank you
all again for coming it's been
absolutely great thank you